foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote for the bone net
of the week you decide we break it down
every Friday in the second hour you know
we broadcast live every single weekday
Monday through Friday two hours on
YouTube Twitter twitch and simulcast to
the mind of such Facebook page but on
Friday Gabe in the second hour there's a
special thing that happens here at the
Tony Michaels podcast we go through the
bone end of the week vote and if you out
there are a new listener you want to
know how to vote don't fret you just go
to at Tony Michael's pod on Twitter
follow us there the poll is there also
Gabe and we want to provide more places
to have this poll and the audience
demanded it so we put it on YouTube so
you can also vote on YouTube so don't
forget to subscribe on YouTube you can
vote for bone net of the week on Twitter
Youtube every Thursday yep game last
night we were working hard on our
project and we started to see these
tweets come in people are like where's
the [ __ ] pole you boneheads where's
the pole boneheads I posted about
Jeffrey Clark in his underwear and and
then I saw someone go Hey where's the
pole which I was like oh my God totally
forgot about so whoever that was if
they're watching thank you for giving me
the reminder yeah Tony and I were busy
in meetings and uh I was like reading
comments and then I saw that one so
whoever that was thank you uh for giving
me the heads up a reminder well we
didn't we didn't want to we didn't want
to be the boneheads we were trying to
hit the bone I mean here's the thing
someday it'll just be us on the show you
know like we'll just be [ __ ] on
ourselves there really is cause that we
could probably be I mean I definitely
could be the bone into the week on the
list every yeah yeah no I'm same same I
mean look at me I'm doing this live
right now this is right I know well it
happens it happens let's let's go to our
poll here
um on Twitter who's the bone out of the
week the contestants this week where
Devin Nunes Herschel Walker and Elon
Musk and Elon Musk I I actually haven't
even looked at the results to be quite
honest with you uh I think they were are
they are they close are they pretty
close let me just let me just check I
don't know what the voters inside that's
the beautiful part of it that's what we
me and Gabe love about the bone end of
the week is we put these contestants out
there and you guys actually get to
decide who you want to be the bonehead
and we just double check the results
here oh I had them in a spreadsheet all
right there's no there's no rigging here
they were uh different levels on each
one but
there was still the first second third
place of each poll okay okay well
democracy democracy is the king here
yeah yeah um and we we have certified
this vote this morning and Gabe has the
vote but here are contestants we have
Devin Nunes Herschel Walker and um not
much
you know two of these guys are kind of
on here for the same damn reason Kinda
Yeah I mean well I don't know I don't
know but Devin who knows maybe he's got
some sort of cow baby but uh I I would
say you mean you mean Kevin you mean
Devin has cows that he would I don't
know not cows he might have calves right
calves or baby cows but I don't know he
might uh ask me or you tell really no
I'm not I wouldn't know I would not even
know I I oh no I mean I know about Cavs
versus cows I'm saying I don't know if
he has baby cats oh I was gonna say I
was gonna say when I was a kid I could I
mean if Devin wants to know how to raise
a calf when I was a kid we had bottle
calves we had a lot of them at any given
point any given time we would get up
early in the morning we'd make bottles
now none of them were actually named
Devin Nunes at the time but if I had a
bottle cap today I think that's probably
what I would name it 2020 hindsight
right yeah you know
years ahead of the joke but man
right well I'm always ahead of the curve
but not that much ahead of the curb so
Gabe tell us tell us um here who who
because I I'm trying to figure out oh I
I see who the winner is yeah yeah see
I'm not even aware of the winner is yeah
you know but but let's so let's start
with uh Mr Elon Musk we love knocking on
Elon here it appears that Elon Musk I
think there's a couple things in the
news here the main thing is this I was
correct from the very beginning he is
going to [ __ ] on this deal he's gonna
[ __ ] the bed on this Twitter deal
there's no way that he's actually going
to buy Twitter yeah um that's one of the
things what's the other thing in the
news though is there another Horror
Story there is not another horse
story per se there's another
um
another story that like I guess you know
the whole like
sexual advance on a plane might lead to
this thing you know if you were to like
actually go through with it which is a
baby turns out it's not just one baby
it's two babies
Elon Musk had twins also while Grimes
was I believed they were trying to get
pregnant or she was pregnant with the
second child meanwhile I mean Grimes and
and Elon aren't together they're they're
they're considered best friends they
love each other and they co-parent
whatever
Rhymes is the artist uh that he was with
and they had their first kid the one
that's like the ex one you remember that
one
it's still one you know it's the one
where it's a bunch of like uh characters
and oh it doesn't actually have a name
yeah it's like the X ae-12 right and
they're like it actually said like hi I
don't know what the actual name sounds
like but when he was in Joe Rogan he
explained what the name sounds like and
Joker was like oh yeah yeah that makes
sense totally makes sense of course it
makes sense to Joe Rogan of course right
right so they have twins uh he had twins
with an exec at one of his companies uh
believe it to be neuralink uh which is
the other one which is basically the
brain implant company that uh a lot that
we basically you know there's this whole
idea yeah this is the one this is the
one that the right Wingers who claim
that uh the vaccine has a chip and it
should be totally against and this is
the one reason why they should [ __ ]
hate Elon Musk more than eight right
right yeah yeah like they hate Bill
Gates for the thing that Elon Musk is
trying to do yep yep I get [ __ ] crazy
because here's here's the thing so like
you the idea is that by implementing
implanting a chip in your brain right
like it'll Advance you as a human
there's this concept called Singularity
right and um and this guy whoa whoa
we're getting pretty deep yeah yeah so
there's this whole thing called
Singularity I won't go too deep into it
right
um but basically it's this idea that
like the only way for us to advance in
society with the with the advancements
and progression that technology does is
to basically
become this like
Synergy right and this is one way where
it's like are they [ __ ] is the chip
[ __ ] you or something
okay yeah it's [ __ ] your brain yeah
yeah exactly okay um so the idea is
through some way to you know the only
way for us to advance
along with and help control kind of
Technology you know especially AI
because it's AI you know it's artificial
intelligence right right and Elon has
said that artificial intelligence is the
is the biggest thing that we should be
afraid of right and the only way to make
sure that it doesn't go beyond us and
basically we have like a Skynet
situation where it's you know Terminator
it's for us to be Skynet is it is for us
to basically become one with you know uh
does he want to have sex with has he
propositioned the computer and it's
possibly I'll buy you a horse if you
just yeah yeah he's like look I'll buy
you a mechanical horse right if you just
well yeah digital horse you know yeah
yeah and it's like not a real or
something right no you can ride a real
world put it in virtual world you can
have all the horses you want as long as
you give me um so anyways uh Elon Musk
uh the typical bonehead always a
bonehead
um a lot of different reasons he [ __ ] on
the Twitter deal of course
um and he had twins and he [ __ ] on other
[ __ ] Christ crime against humanity I
mean one of them his daughter uh has
successfully removed herself from any
and all connection to him she was like I
don't want anything to do with you
because I know one of them is an adult
right she just turned 18 and then also
got a name and a gender change and the
the judge here in the LA court uh oh
okay signed off on it I see I see so so
so just keep in mind not even elon's
kids when they're legally available to
be do not want to be associated with him
at all I don't either but we have to
talk about him because he is a [ __ ]
bonehead speaking of talking about
boneheads Devin Nunes
he really he really [ __ ] the bet on the
true social thing this is a guy Devin
Nunes is the guy who held a seat in
California that was probably a safe seat
for congress he could have remained a
congressperson he resigned abruptly this
isn't like he's like oh I'm not gonna
run yeah yeah he's like I'm done I'm
gonna go be the the the Fall Guy for
true I'm the CEO for True social right
and that what happened
yeah yeah basically he was like I'm done
I'm gone I uh uh I see this opportunity
this once in a lifetime opportunity yeah
it's a great opportunity
of this Trump World and Trump technology
or whatever the [ __ ] it's called well I
really I don't blame Devin Nunez here
because he really wanted to go over to
True social and make sure that they
couldn't open accounts that had anything
to do with cows like he really wanted to
put a stop to that that was his main
priority his main goal here I'm sure it
was his main motivation I do want to
make one correction I saw in the chat
here and actually thank you for
correcting me he doesn't have nine kids
he has ten kids oh he's 10 children
sorry apologies I just want to crime
against you I got one crime again yeah
procreating is yeah Against Humanity uh
but back to Devin yeah Devin is a guy
who so so sensitive so sensitive God
forbid
an account on Twitter as as a as a cow
he felt so threatened by it that he
wanted to take legal action
uh that's that Twitter account that's
run by a cow the Kevin uh the Deva Nunez
cow very funny person very funny account
and the fact that you're going to take
legal action to go against an account
because they're like oh it's not even
gonna say anything really mean or
anything like
defamatory it's just they're [ __ ]
making fun of you right right they're
joking they're amazing
yeah he's like they can't say that and
it's like dude Free Speech bro do you
think do you think um Trump used
something against Evan Nunes to get him
to do this because I don't believe that
you would give up a congressional seat
to do this type of [ __ ] I don't know I
mean
leave the [ __ ] well I mean Devin
Nunes everyone knew this Trump true
social thing was a bunch of oh yeah it
was a couch
the thing is Devin Nunes has been
Trump's lap dog for a long time for
years right I mean uh there were the
moments when
I'm trying to remember the exact event
but he was running basically between
right his office and the White House
just give them information illusion I
gave you a heads up this is what they're
saying about the Mueller investigation
and then run back and they really run
back I mean like the most active amount
of time in his ever in his life ever
right he was running a marathon between
both office and the White House it's
kind of made him famous it kind of
famous I mean he you know I think there
was one report where like interview
where he was caught kind of they're like
what are you doing he's like oh
I was just giving a
I was just giving Trump a heads up and
they're like what and he's like oh no
they gotta go and then he you know runs
off but Devin Nunes is is that type of
person where he will I don't know if he
has something on he very well could have
something on him or he could just be
like that much of a cook and he says hey
guys I love Trump I really want I really
want I'll be honest I really wanted
Devin Nunez as the alpha cook but we
couldn't we couldn't not put him on the
bonehead list right yeah because well
what you tweet here Trump's media
company has become an utter failure and
now Devin Nunes is left holding a big
bag of cow [ __ ] because it is likely
that if there is Criminal prosecutions
Devin Nunes will be at the Forefront of
these prosecutions and let me let me
tell you something folks these
prosecutors all around this country now
that Trump is exposed and he's
vulnerable to criminal prosecutions and
boy are they gonna pile on so anywhere
they can they will power on whether it's
about true social it's about January 6
his business in New York whether it's
about the actual document that's
classified documents that he stole from
the White House there's going to be a
lot of [ __ ] that's going to come down on
this stupid bastard but Harold Trevino
has the that you retweeted
um the the actual story here right Devin
noon is such a dumb [ __ ] and he's such a
bonehead is just a couple weeks before
there were Federal subpoenas to the true
social what what's it called the the
actual company Trump [ __ ] Trump trump
technology Trump facts machine
technology or some [ __ ] they actually
had a fax number I think in their
company media and Technology Group oh
media and Technology Group okay so it's
and it's all a fraud right it's all a
fraud I mean to tell you this much it
Trump leaves this group
should should be as much of a red flag
as anything right just the name Trump in
the actual company name is like ah maybe
just maybe I should stay away from that
you know yeah it's like look he's
leaving the company that owns the app
that is all about truth
and it's all about him yeah I mean I
mean they said true social the only
reason why true social exists is for
Donald Trump to tweet and for everyone
to [ __ ] jerk him off because he's
tweeted yeah that's it that's why that's
why we have the alpha Cup this week
um because we like to make fun of it
over there every now and again and you
do a great job of making fun of it over
there but I mean there are actual
statements over there now we don't post
a lot of the real ones it but I
encourage people to actually go over and
look at them yeah see how this guy is I
mean we did we did share the ones that
happened in real time that we thought
were important which happens exactly
right you know because someone's giving
a testimony he was [ __ ] him his
pants changing the diaper and he's been
freaking out this weekend he's freaking
out probably today right now because of
Pat cipolloni
um because if Patrick baloney actually
testifies and does does not take the
fifth he is [ __ ] but here's the thing
with this actual uh probe this Federal
probe for subpoenas they're probing the
actual investment structure of true
social because it looks like it's a
monitoring laundering scheme and what is
funny about this is someone tipped down
on Trump and Donald Trump Jr off here
someone tipped him off because they left
the board just weeks before it was
subpoenaed
and and Devin Nunes is left like you
said holding the big pile of cow [ __ ]
um and Donald Trump and Donald Trump Jr
have skated away from these subpoenas at
least for now
um in this in this uh scheme this
investment scheme of true social so we
will actually and there was two Federal
subpoenas we'll probably be seeing more
yeah but the board members were I mean
the other board member The Other Board
member was Cash Patel that was taken off
too which I think is significant in the
January 6th stuff it's almost like
Donald Trump
uh tipped off cash Patel too to make
sure he wouldn't go because he's been
one that has not been Cooperative with
the January 6th election yeah
it's almost like cash Patel knows
something and Donald Trump is giving him
benefits for knowing these things and
not saying them it almost seems that way
it almost I mean because who knows right
like
you know much like Marjorie Taylor
Green's kind of uh the the trial that
she had about the Georgia election
they're asking questions because you
know one they wanted to get the answer
but two they wanted it on the official
record because then it can be used
against her so you know I wouldn't be
surprised if there was some sort of uh
kind of collaboration on this or some
sort of foresight to say if we get the
subpoena and we ask this person
questions maybe it's tangentially
related but it's on the record right and
it opens the door for other questions or
an investigation
and if Trump or whoever is kind of
advising him to say look you need to
room anyone anyone at all that knew or
had some sort of Whisper of what
happened on January 6 because what
they're going to do possibly is they're
going to come after one of these people
and then they're gonna they're gonna get
them to open up and say great we won't
prosecute you on this thing that we're
investigating if you also talk about
this right
why I think there's going to be a lot of
that in the Trump World yeah and I'm
speaking of [ __ ] in the Trump World
because we'll move on from the boneheads
we're going to move on to the dishonor
one of our dishonorable mentions here
and we're talking about him earlier and
unjustice Brett Kavanaugh and this
[ __ ] thinks he has the right to
go into a restaurant and have a steak
it's not a right it's a privilege and
Morton's actually steps in I think it
happened at Morton's Steakhouse right
this is a company yeah I've never
they've got all of it we've got one in
Chicago I mean they're all over the
place right but I I've never been into a
Morton's is it any good have you been to
one I've been to one yeah I've been to
I've been to the one in Chicago that's
off of uh State Street and uh it's okay
I mean there's nothing special about it
you know the the show uh the league uh
it was on FX like that's based there
they always meet or the next the Mortons
or whatever it is downtown
um but it's you know it's a steakhouse
right like it's the only I would say
like the
American kind of thing like you know
everything else we kind of like take
from other people right like oh this
type of food and I feel like Steakhouse
is like the only kind of
quasi-american type of like dish or like
you know setting right that's that right
it's been around so but yeah there's
nothing really like special about it
it's not like incredibly fine dining you
could walk in there right well I mean
you could go to other chains like
Colton's or Texas Roadhouse or yeah yeah
any of these other places when you could
get just as good of a cut of meat and
it's not like Morton stands out but
apparently
um Brett Kavanaugh was in the DC Mortons
there's apparently a Morton's in DC
which it would make sense that that
Brett Kavanaugh would go to a you know a
a
stupidly branded Steakhouse right I mean
that makes sense and think that it's
some kind of [ __ ] right uh big huge
deal
um but the the thing is is after
apparently some abortion rights activist
came in and were yelling or Screaming or
disrupting the dinner and he had to
leave
um and mortens was very upset yeah
Morton's was very upset now Morton's has
the right to actually kick those
protesters is out they just like when we
talk about the people who were going to
Burger King demanding a Whopper and
causing a big Ruckus they actually had
the right to ask them to leave just like
mortens has the right to ask me believe
but Morton's kind of stepped in it here
they step in where they actually were
saying but they didn't they didn't even
go inside from what I read they were
outside right so that's what I mean
that's right yeah is as long as they
remained outside right and as long as
they remained off of a Morton's property
just like people were outside on public
property for you know any of the
justices especially Brett Kavanaugh's
home right but in in the case where they
were good to go inside mortens has the
right to get them off of their property
but once they're off the property they
can yell and scream I made this case
before uh with a Whopper thing where
people were saying this and I said well
you know it's kind of like you don't
have the freedom to go into a business
and do whatever you want like you can't
walk into Mortons and jump over the
counter and run in the back and cook
your own steak you don't have the right
to do that that's it's their business
it's their private property
um they're running a business they have
the right to operate it without
impediment of you being a silly [ __ ]
right right and that's they have that
they actually have that right because
they have a business license with the
government
um so but here's the thing is that you
don't have the right to go paint on the
walls at Walmart that you hate [ __ ]
Walmart but you do have the right to
stand on the public sidewalk it's
outside Walmart not on their property
but off their property and yell and
scream that you hate Walmart that's the
freedom of speech that's the actual
freedom of speech now people practicing
their freedom of speech here and
Morton's being upset that Brett
Kavanaugh had to leave his dinner early
they really didn't even get his dessert
Tony oh man you know that's probably the
most disappointing dessert sounds like
the steak sucked and he was waiting for
the uh the chocolate malted cake with
the ice you know what I'm talking about
most of these steakhouses yeah they have
the same things the molten chocolate
anyway with the big lava cake inside
yeah right well it's got the Scoopa and
then they put the fudge on the it's
[ __ ] most places it's pretty [ __ ]
good I'm not gonna lie yeah I'm not
gonna lie you can tell I like food I
like food and I don't blame I don't
blame Brett gammonov or being a little
upset that he didn't get his his uh his
dessert and he probably had to cry in
his beer because there were people
outside calling him a fascist but this
goes to the video that we watched uh of
Rudy Giuliani and Andrew Giuliani the
other day
um where people are yelling and
screaming at them and not giving them
peace in public
you know if you're gonna show your face
in public from now on if you're a
fascist and you try to overturn our
government you try to take our are are
[ __ ]
um our democracy away from us then yeah
we're not gonna We're not gonna put up
with that and we're gonna call you what
you are I mean there you you I love this
you took an action there is a
consequence I love this picture by the
way [ __ ] goddess because this this
shows you this now this isn't I don't
this isn't outside the Mortons but it
just shows you
um what people are about and with
President Biden signing the executive
order today this only gives more people
more hope against uh fascist [ __ ] like
the Brett Kavanaugh and scotus that
Democrats are going to try to protect
Reproductive Rights Republicans are the
ones trying to rip it away yeah
are not pro-life crazy oh who to thunk
it so there you have the dishonorable
mention of the day just as Brett
Kavanaugh which brings us to the alpha
cook and I'm not gonna spend much time
on this but um because we really gotta
we really gotta to get to our winner
here yeah and before we close
but our Alpha cook has a special place
in our heart by also keep in mind this
was the audience
vote this week that's right that's right
that's what the people wanted if we did
if the person who is the alpha cook is
watching and they're offended by this we
did not choose this yeah
right we let them lose it was a very
Democrat or tried to be a democratic
process we are allies of democracy right
we are not a danger
and we definitely we definitely will not
we will not we will not laugh at the
expense of someone for our demo we are
very serious here game we do not operate
this satire ahead of the week
we definitely do not operate in the in
the realm of satire parody Or even even
laughing that would be egregious and
that is a danger to our democracy to
Laugh To Laugh
to laugh and have humor that would be a
danger Tony laughing laughing's not a
right it's a privilege I know I
know and we have our Alpha Kaka the week
here Seth who as we refer to him now
said who said who
um because again I didn't know who this
was until he told is nearly one million
followers to block me right he's a self
he's a self-proclaimed journalist is
what he is
um this this self-proclaimed journalists
somebody in the chat here said that we
should make sure to put a disclaimer on
it
redo the tile quick make sure to Market
satire and it's safe safe for Seth
aberson to look at it otherwise he might
be confused oh my God it could be a
danger it could top our democracy at any
moment for this child to be up yeah God
forbid the January 6th hearings or
anything else that's happening the
governor raises it's all about that 2024
race and Trump versus DeSantis that's
right and if you make any jokes
whatsoever about it you are the problem
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
I hope he keeps doing Instagram lives
though I think it brought I think it
brought us some viewers so thanks thanks
Seth you Seth who said for all the you
who who who uh for all the new followers
that Gabe says uh thank you very much
for helping us out and giving us a boost
giving us a boost in the in the uh
follower category this week because
what's good for Gabe is good for the
show so and by the way by the way go
follow Gabe at IMDb ninjas and the show
and Tony yeah yeah follow it all follow
it all but make sure make sure to stuff
it in the alpha Cook's face because
that's really why you should be the
alpha cook it's because he thought he
was an alpha he got butt hurt because he
got tricked by your satire which is was
a beautiful piece of satire if I do say
so myself and he got tricked by it he
got butt hurt he got pissed off that he
didn't do his due diligence he got egg
on his face he didn't look like the
journalist that he proclaims to be yeah
because he couldn't do two minutes worth
of research to figure out that this
what's in the statement on true social
he [ __ ] up he got mad it got personal
for him he actually came and he [ __ ]
tried to pull an elf on you and tell
people to block you right and he got
cucked hard yeah I mean you know I I
said it yesterday I was like I have no
problem with him having an issue with
the with a piece of content
he could have easily made a different
tweet he could have sent me a message
you know he's a big account I'm sure he
can find his way to this journalist he
could have messages
that's the biggest thing right one
making the assumption that I was BR I
was bragging in my bio which was not
related to this release he made the
assumption that it was me who made it
and then the fact that he did not do his
research and he posted it and then
somebody said it's not real and then he
said oh shoot and then decided whether
you know an emotional state or he felt
embarrassed or it's personal he took it
out on me he went on Instagram live for
like three hours and talked about this
guy this guy couldn't say you're [ __ ]
saying it wasn't really three hours okay
you have to put a disclaimer on this oh
my God yeah
Jesus Christ let's start a thread it'll
be a long thread right I'll explain 160
000 [ __ ] uh tweets and a thread of
why we disclaim that Seth who is an
alpha cook he's the [ __ ] Alpha cook
you know we should do we should take
that tile and post that some [ __ ] on
Twitter and let people spread that
around I'm just saying no doubt we
definitely want to Market satire though
on Twitter because there's two things we
gotta mark one and it's a joke and two
that other people voted for it we didn't
vote for it right it's not it's not a
joke it's I'm serious he is an alpha
cook it's not a joke Seth you're an
alpha cook okay we don't we don't
discriminate here we I'm not not only do
we go against these [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you see here but we also attack
people who who who claim to be good for
democracy but do do opposite when they
attack pro-democracy people and
pro-democracy content
so let's get back to the bonehead of the
week we have the winner mm-hmm uh
Herschel Walker was our winner what was
it you said it was close it was closer
was it not close in the aggregate uh in
the aggregate it was not close for him
it was kind of close between Nunes and
musk but uh it wasn't close Okay so he
got out front for Herschel Walker yeah
yeah he you think it's just because he
he's like just inherently a bonehead
like it it doesn't really have to do
with the story yeah well I mean it's
it's a story that's out there for
bonehead it's a continuation of a story
that's already happened but also also
the only thing that happened what am I
missing this morning
another another uh which I didn't get
too much time to read into but basically
the gist of it is he partnered in 2012
with this Energy company and they've
been accused by multiple
by multiple states of deceptive
practices
so let me say that again Herschel Walker
partnered in 2012 with an arm of an
energy company and he was accused by
multiple states of deceptive practices
which is interesting because he also got
charged or investigated for deceptive
practices under his veteran organization
right so this guy has a track record
there is a behavior in a pattern in
place where he does the same [ __ ] but
for different people so this is an
energy this isn't the chicken company
that he owns this is not the chicken
he's always talking about the veteran
company this is not him graduating the
top one percent and actually graduating
from University of Georgia this is about
wait wait wait you're telling me he
didn't graduate from the University of
Georgia the UGA you're telling me that
I'm I'm just saying the facts facts yeah
the facts you know our Alpha guck maybe
may be able to go do a little bit of
research on that for us
um here's Christopher has a new Herschel
Walker partner with an industry company
Accused by multiple states of deceptive
practices sounds like a match made in
Heaven since deception is on brand for
Walker Herschel Walker isn't worth
worthy of being Georgia's Senator that's
for sure CNN has the article here I mean
the more and more that news comes out
about Herschel Walker the more and more
he becomes the perfect ideal candidate
for the Republican party right and we'll
have the right deals
I mean just Place him on there every
there's a lot of people we can place on
this pole but even this week right so
like the story that was in a as you were
as you were mentioned earlier is a
continuation of the story of his his
secret children right it has an Elon
Musk smell to it it it's got a bit of a
must and sure yeah for sure and you you
you find out that not only did he have
these three additional children that he
did not disclose right and he was like
oh no everybody knows it I've been very
honest about it uh and I've told my
campaign turns out
Herschel Walker is notorious for lying
and he dodged the claims about whether
you know the team didn't know he had
multiple SQL secret children turns out
he kept the campaign team in the dark he
didn't tell anyone nobody knew until The
Daily Beast dropped that article that
exposed him for the liar that he is and
the the person that Crea is creating
broken homes fatherless homes the thing
that Herschel Walker is is like the
thing that he goes against right he has
campaigned against the societal problems
we have in America are all doing can be
traced back to fatherless homes yet he
is a creator of three of those homes
foreign
and he lied to his campaign about all
this right and now people now now people
in the campaign are coming out and being
like this is [ __ ] ridiculous nobody
knew we were all right guys did you see
the uh uh video where Lauren Windsor
asked him if he had had abortions have
you seen this video because that's one
is that the one where he's at what looks
like he's at Mar-A-Lago or some sort of
event and he kind of like walks it off
or it's a different one here it is let's
let's watch hi there
and I think
see you later
I am how are you ready
thank you so much
thank you so much and I really you know
I don't want to sound rude and ask of
this but you know as a Christian and all
the attacks that you're going through
right now and I understand that you know
you had other children
[Music]
by the way like she told us I mean oh my
God she's [ __ ] she's like as a
Christian I totally know you're under
attack like Christian you're under
attack and he's like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I feel I feel for what you're going
through right now like she's very good
oh she's [ __ ] excellent to get these
stupid bastards the time I do wonder I
want to ask hopefully we can get her on
the show I I we've had like uh some back
and forth trying yeah we're trying to
get her on the show but we're both busy
with different things happening right so
one thing she's very busy out there yeah
right right so it's like finding the
time would be amazing but I do have one
question which is like when you go to
these places right because she's had
she's had Senator Ron Johnson multiple
times in terms on video in different
events so what I want to know is is she
wearing different setup like yeah he has
to know who she is now because there is
that recent video of her and Ron Johnson
in the airport I believe it's right
board where in a terminal where she's
talking to him and asking about the the
the envelope that was given to Mike
Pence by his staff he was trying to
blame the staff it's really unclear
rather Ron Johnson's a traitor not well
I mean it's not that unclear and the
evidence will come out Ron Johnson you
are the [ __ ] Putin's puppet and
you're a traitor but we'll find that out
but there's that one where she I think I
think at some point they know who she is
right it's hard to maybe disguise
yourself so I would like to ask her that
too like at what point Have you ever
walked up to one of these people and
they're like I know you are we don't see
we don't see her side so it's like are
you going in like Sasha Baron Cohen and
you've got you gotta hold the skies on
or are you like very nice I like it's
like if you get someone else you know
eventually I think it's gonna get to the
point where she's got to like send in
other you know like operatives we'll
call them
to pretend
in most cases she has to pretend one
really stroke this this right gross
fascist Christian [ __ ] whether she's
tricking them like she is here let's
watch
greater wife I could still support you
though
I don't want it to come to officer at
all but you've never heard like funded
an abortion or no call somebody no no of
course not I wouldn't lie about it
either no I lie about everything else so
why would I lie about this no come on
come on you believe this for a second
no of course of course he's paid of
course he's at course of course just
like Donald Trump he's right he's paid
you know he's had someone to do an NDA
you know it would be a question for
Michael Cohen you know as well I would
doubt I would doubt Elon Musk has
because he's got ten he seems to be like
yep seems to be totally right he's like
look when they come out they get their
own they get their own Tesla ready to go
let's you know it's Tesla crib let's
let's finish watching abortion because I
just
you know the the stuff about your
children you're standing up and you're
being a good man
um
okay so she approaches him she's got she
has got some kahunas here too yeah
because she knows she's like you know
she's in these events there's a lot of
security around some of these people
um you know don't and and she's she's
right up against him she's not like back
shouting away from them she's right up
to him she's right in their Grill she's
asking the questions that everyone wants
to know and she's also like on the Fly
is able to be like boom right you know
continue with the you know she's
obviously got a character which is more
or less the same character for everyone
which is like you're white you're
Christian you know you believe in God
it's a Republican party these are all
things that you know the character
doesn't really need to change at all for
the people that she's coming after but
she's very very good about like on the
Fly being like cool okay cool this is
what I like oh yeah no totally like very
endearing and you know understanding
them as the victim you know making sure
that they feel important right right
that way they'll exactly their guts you
know it reminds me as we sit here and
think about this and watch her her
Herschel Walker be the bonehead of the
week here but um Lauren Windsor is what
James O'Keefe wishes he was right like
undercurrent does what project Veritas
claims to do yeah right they always set
it up they're always in a restaurant
it's always pre-staged and [ __ ] she's
not doing that she's going straight to
the [ __ ] source she's talking to
these people she's getting
um the actual footage of it right there
and so thank you Lauren for for the
video of the bone end of the week
Herschel Walker because he is a bonehead
so Gabe let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just want to point out to everybody
that Herschel Walker in that in that uh
that animated uh video that we do every
day he really looked like an uncondom
boner in the middle there I'm just
saying and maybe maybe just if anybody
out there don't cut that up and put a
condom over it I'm just saying
um Herschel Walker doesn't seem to know
how to use one yeah and just just just
giving you that piece of advice so thank
you for Herschel Walker being our bone
end of the week and thank you for voting
everyone for bone end of the week make
sure to go to at the Tony Michaels pod
on Twitter and follow me and Gabe
definitely follow Gabe and piss off the
alpha cuck that we have this week get
that following up there way up there and
go follow us and you can vote on at Tony
Michael's pod you also need to subscribe
to the YouTube channel subscribe I like
that graphic And subscribe to YouTube
channel you can also vote for Bonet a
week there every Thursday you guys know
we broadcast our show every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and we sign on cast
from the Midas touch Facebook page but
on Fridays in the second hour we do bone
end of the week where you vote for the
bone of the week you decide and we break
it down for bone end of the week thanks
for joining us for this edition of Bonet
of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]